Shireen Baratheon: The Dance of Dragons.
It's the story of the fight between Rhaenyra
Targaryen and her half-brother Aegon
for control of the Seven Kingdoms.
A True Telling by Grand Maester Munkun,
being a history of the war of Targaryen
succession between the Princess Rhaenyra
and Aegon, Second of his name, that nearly
destroyed the realm.
Viserys Targaryen:
One night, a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep. Protocol dictated
that the bells would be rung and a raven sent to
Dragonstone to summon the heir, Princess Rhaenyra,
for her coronation. But Alicent had other plans.
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King and
father to Queen Alicent, demanded that
the succession be settled immediately.
The old king had forced the lords of Westeros to
swear fealty to Princess Rhaenyra as his heir.
But Ser Criston Cole rightly
pointed out that a son
comes before a daughter.
Shireen:
Both of them thought they belonged on the Iron
Throne. When people started declaring for one of
them or the other, their fight divided the
kingdoms in two. Brothers fought brothers,
dragons fought dragons. By the time it was over,
thousands were dead. And it was a disaster for the
Targaryens as well. They never truly recovered.
Varys:
During the great Targaryen civil war known
as "the Dance of the Dragons," a king and
queen each vied for the throne, dividing their
house and its dragons against each other.
Eventually, the queen was fed to her rival's
dragons while her son watched, and the
victorious king soon died of his own wounds.
By the war's end, King's Landing was smashed,
cities razed and sacked never to be rebuilt,
and dragons had faded from this world.